[Music]
last time on transformers Optimus Prime
sold his soul to the devil better known
to humanity as Michael Pig
in exchange for three hit movies a
shitload of cash and a new pal
popularity in the public eye but little
did he know that the movies would only
get worse and worse leading his audience
to an ungodly amount of boredom that
stupidity still popular and still rich
Prime finds himself hanging on to little
dignity and street cred to make things
worse Bay has lost his connection with
the geek community due to rumor changes
to the Ninja Turtles franchise so prime
has been sent out to rebuild the hide
for transformers for explosion of the
boobs he has been sent to anime st.
Louis with his agent to recruit extras
for his next movie greetings humanity I
am Optimus Prime who wants to see
explosions who wants to see giant robots
who wants to see racial stereotypes
exploited to an embarrassing degree nice
to see hot ladies insultingly
objectified with no identifiable
intelligence or personality even the
women cheered that one well who wants to
see Shia LaBeouf alright alright there's
some hope for you yet
well we're having auditions for
Transformers for
[Applause]
the auditions did not go well well he's
no Shia LaBeouf but he might be able to
pull off carrot top
no no you're trying to think BAE doesn't
like that just drape yourself over a car
and wilcott what you showed up to a
Michael Bay audition and you didn't
bring a car to drape yourself over well
surely you have a motorcycle in your
pocket that you can press your breast
against narced all right you're the
sassy best friend Christ Jerry did you
see the look on their faces when I
mentioned the movie all that misguided
optimism it's like telling a blind kid
they're gonna pet a bunny and when
really it's a porcupine
look the product sells and you're still
popular so is Jersey Shore you last film
grossed 1 billion 123 million worldwide
but at what cost charity at what cost I
told you 1 billion 123 million worldwide
now get some sleep
we got more auditions to get through I'm
gonna go do coke off a prostitute who
was also doing coke and a hot tub that's
not physically possible I'll find a way
it wasn't always like this
I used to have credibility dignity a hit
show that brought joy to millions of
children around the world and not just
horny mentally castrated teenagers these
were the days of the original
transformer cartoon
[Music]
oh it was violent and the writing wasn't
exactly Shakespeare but we had a
connection to our young audience an
exciting connection that while not deep
or complex per se it supplied an
onslaught of creativity simple fun and
exciting adventure you may mock its
corniness at times but I assure you
there is more here than Michael Bay has
ever put in his perverted seemless don't
believe me well then allow Optimus Prime
to show you the first episode entitled
more than meets the eye
gave us the back story on our proud
history on the planet Cybertron
intelligent robots that could think and
feel inhabited the cities they were
called Autobots and Decepticons but The
Frugal Decepticons were driven by a
single goal total domination in
hindsight we probably should seen that
coming I mean they were called
Decepticons kind of obvious but we were
declaring war at the time on the
trustworthy ins that was probably stupid
too we see two Autobots Wheeljack and
bumblebee ride through a pretty deserted
Cybertron until they come across the
Decepticons
like most transformers they brilliantly
set their guns to shoot everything
around the target except the target we
feel that gave the opponent a fighting
chance any luck yes negative in our side
of Cybertron's back up an inside of the
driveshaft I'm still not sure why we
hire Bill Cosby to do jails so while we
dunk about a plans to find a new energy
source of metal burn named laser big
mapping listen indoors right now
sure enough the Decepticons led by
Megatron are given the information by
Laserbeak and his master Soundwave now
you might be wondering why a guy who
clearly just stated he's going to betray
him would be allowed to be kept in
because he makes great cookies
Starscream cookies are more than meets
the eye say you're wrong Starscream I'm
always wrong so while we proud Autobots
try to leave Cybertron for a new energy
source the Decepticons attack thus
losing control leading us to crash on
the planet known as earth this doesn't
put our incredible technologically
advanced bodies out of commission for
long just four million years what do you
want our boot up system was Windows 7
I'm surprised we woke up this fast
the Decepticons woke first and tried to
destroy our remains while looking for
new sources of energy they do this to
stew try and take control of Cybertron
which
I'm sure is exactly the same right after
we left 4 million years nothing much
happens in that time but we escaped and
spread out thus locating the Decepticons
trying to find a way to harness energy
jumper what are you doing
I've got Megatron dead center in my
viewfinder it should be noted that the
term dead center in my viewfinder is an
Autobot phrase meaning slightly to the
left but I'm going to shoot anyway we
Autobots are proud of that phrase what
they did manage to work their way back
to the Autobots and tell us of the
Decepticons evil plans
we of course lept into action organize a
battle unit we're going after them admit
it you could hear that sound effect for
hours if you could choose the sound of
your orgasm it would be that sound and
you know it yes of course it is made
better by the calling out of our awesome
names sunstreaker science right little
known fact you're some of the other
kick-ass names that were not used for
other transformers cold iron metal stab
violins speed dick thrust nut jab Jesus
punch bill and tic-tac ler I
particularly said that one didn't make
it in
so the Decepticons tried to steal the
energy from an oil drill where a kid
named spike and his father sparkplug
I thought our names were weird notice
the attack
what is it why are they but thankfully
they used their brilliant human
ingenuity and fight them off the best
way they know how
throwing things
[Music]
stop let go bye dad
Wow
I forgot how embarrassing that scene was
for him he gave you like a solid second
look of shame and that SWAT you like a
mosquito dad fuck you asshole I am now
convinced that his spike was an Autobot
his transformer name would be pussy pill
ho a name of great shame to say the
least
so we Autobots come in to save sparkplug
and pussy pillow when Megatron suddenly
transforms into the duck hunt gone
[Music]
luckily only two people were on that oil
rig well that's the story we're going
with if we want continued children's
programming syndication and we saved
them just in time for part 2 of the
story arc this begins with spike writing
like a girl in his journal describing
his predicament the Autobots are a
highly advanced form of robot I don't
really know if they're from the past or
the future but they can think and have
real feelings Michael Bay we're here
right now we have two annoying parents
come in not knowing how to react we eat
a pop rowdy Mike here wants to know how
we transform around a Z like this what
other tricks can you do try this one
spike now you see man now you don't
oh now of course you might be asking
yourself why the hell we don't just use
that technique about a bajillion other
times in the show well I think the real
question is how can Soundwave transform
from a handheld tape deck into a
two-story monstrosity we Autobots
proudly honor the code of equal value
proportions except for the cargo I'm
carrying as a truck that seems to
disappear and reappear at will you may
also be wondering what I'm carrying
inside that cargo that's so important to
constantly keep around well I'll tell
you Starscream cookies and the sprinkles
on top are simply to die for sausages
let me cut batch spike discovers however
that Soundwave has snuck in and thus he
pushes the alarm that is in no way
labeled alarm smart kid which forces him
to leave his Thundercat ravage behind oh
no my agent can know why bad-mouthing
the movie appraising the other show is
better
[Music]
the Transformers will return after these
messages
we now return to the Transformers I must
use my powers of disguise to blend in
Autobot transform why gee I wonder where
he could be he's such a master of
camouflage he could be anywhere well if
you're in here speed on stairs a little
bit anyway so ravage is captured but we
figure out the Decepticons are gonna try
and get more energy from a dam
so as you can see they're being attacked
by Cubans that you'll kill that
Cybertron
so Starscream uses one of his deadliest
weapons a slingshot Wow I think the only
thing we didn't make a toy out of was
the actual toy which of course upsets
Megatron Megatron yesterday's model
Chuck that's what you are whoa did I
really just use the J word that's why
you suck time
the Autobots come to my aid as well as
big shock
pussy fellow here hey Z spike oh dear oh
oh I should have caught that yes that
looks very suggestive yeah we're not
doing the children's educational route
without that scene being edited I am
deeply ashamed
[Music]
oddly enough playing that isn't helping
meanwhile Starscream and Megatron bitch
at each other again like a senile couple
I never did understand why he didn't
just propose not even his cookies can
get him out of this one
with just a dash at all screwed
Wow that was dark but Decepticons trying
to get energy from a mineshaft but
luckily we were there to stop them again
unfortunately they buried us under a ton
of debris but we escaped without a
scratch on us or the humans so just to
reiterate being crushed by a ton of
rocks no problem at all crashing the
ship into a volcano
four million year recovery it is
important to know this if not it would
sound incredibly stupid this leads to
our conclusion in part three here we get
the idea to fool ravage into thinking
we've revealed our plan and let him go
only to plan a trap to capture the
Decepticons what they didn't fall for it
because we're really bad actors he told
me teletraan once located a secret
supply of rocket fuel were not too far
from here about a hundred and forty
kilometers due west why there's enough
rocket fuel at that base to make four
trips to Cybertron can't believe he went
to the Actors Studio is why our marriage
Council that says we're never going to
grow as a couple you've also made kill
your desire to replace me as leader of
the Decepticons mistake why now of
course if I was leading I would shoot
the bastard and not wait for a mistake
number two Hey look mistake number two
[Music]
yet he still lets him stay you know I'm
aware of the phrase keep your friends
close and keep your enemies closer
me personally I'm a fan of keep your
friends close and kill the son of a
bitch who's been betraying you every
single chance he gets it is the Autobot
way so the Decepticons use our trap and
turn it into a trap on us pulling off a
deceptive con if you will seriously I
don't know we didn't put together they
were gonna be the bad guys with that
name I mean I'm so embarrassed but he
used this time to get enough energy to
head back to Cybertron while we prepare
to make our final stand space cruiser
fuel and ready for departure you know it
just hit me and I the only one who
realizes that Soundwave does all the
work and yet we know so little about him
I mean doesn't someone with that
intelligence and passion have any dreams
Soundwave ready the army I want a story
on something that gives me depth I want
to romance yes a romantic comedy
perhaps a relationship with the toaster
the toaster can be stuck-up and high
class I will be quirky and giving in to
all sorts of antics at first she doesn't
like me but then she admires my silly
charm we get to know each other better
but then she discovers I was keeping a
secret the whole time I tried to explain
I held this secret because I love her
but she's too emotional and filled with
hate so she decides to marry this snob a
real uptight guy with no funny lines
she's about to be Wed at the altar but
then I come stumbling in after going
through some sort of comedic chase I
plead myself to her and at first it
looks like she's not buying it but then
her eyes tear up she turns around gives
me a hug the shinobi groom is angry but
then my comedic sidekick comes in and
punches him the crowd cheers I tell the
toaster I love her she says she loves me
we decided to get married but we do not
show a touchscreen because two weddings
would just be repetitive so we ended
with kind of an open ending something
like we're trying to get convertible
into the sunset or something this leaves
it open for a sequel I want to be played
by Zac Efron and Natalie Portman as the
toaster there is a bit of an age
difference but I think she looks young
enough she can pull it off
Disney has shown interest Gary Marshall
is attached to direct it will be pulled
some waves of the haunt it will be rated
pg-13 for crude humor and adult
situations but nothing too bad just
enough to let the male demographic know
that it's edgy and we'll have some
gross-out humor for them and the female
demographic will instantly be drawn to
the toaster they will be able to imagine
themselves inserted into the role it
will be released in summer preferably
over a holiday weekend it will break
records win awards it will be the
sleeper hit of the year now dammit
so we have our epic battle but it
appears Megatron still gets away or does
he total victory is within my grasp I
see that you have learned nothing
Starscream he'll are nothing if there
was a book about how to learn nothing
your picture will be on the back of it I
can't believe we lost Cybertron to these
bozos but one of our Autobot sneaks
aboard and sets the ship to fly into the
ocean sinking them into the very depths
ready spike it's almost time to blast
off I'll be right there Prime
one more thing I sure am glad we don't
have to worry about Megatron and all
those Decepticons anymore yeah you may
want to put a dot dot dot after that kid
ah yes that was the story arc of the
mighty Autobots you know it's a touch
sillier than I remember it I suppose
looking back it's not quite as grand as
I remember sure there wasn't much
emphasis on character sure the stories
were pretty repetitive then sure we were
just as focused on advertising as any
other show but you know what we still
created something all our own our
designs were created our episode's
action-packed every second filled with
energy and excitement we knew how to
make our audiences happy and we did it
well it may not be the best show but it
was a show that knew what it was and who
it was trying to entertain and it tried
hard every second it could to give you
that action-packed entertainment that
you all loved which is why I asked all
of you gathered here today in this world
of remakes sequels and emphasis on
special effects
who the fuck just wants to watch some
transformers cartoons
and fucking yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yes